I got kicked out of your house for being
a drug addict when you were in high
school I used to sell drugs as well that
was the real reason oh my God that's the
hardest I laughed when uh
the original turbo Vine yeah that's from
like the OG beginning
studies I used to spend they're very
close friends the way that you said I
saw ecstasy into children at Raves was
so hysterically funny well it's because
I didn't say it my friend get her one of
the studies it was his voice okay but
yeah it was crazy yeah that whole thing
with that that was the first time I ever
dressed like that and that was like the
original character that was a joke by
the way
you know
[Laughter]
yeah there it is classic but yeah that
was the thing where I showed up to a
music video shoot I had my first chance
to be in a music video that would reach
MTV well I don't know if it was mtv2 at
the time or whatever it was but I was
like okay how do I want to present
myself do I want to sell sex and like
try to be like everyone else or do I
want to try to make myself look as ugly
as possible so that I can stand out and
be stick out like a sore thumb amongst
all these other people selling sex so
for me it was like the first thing so I
was like what can I do and I just pulled
things from my youth you know the bull
cut was the haircut I had my whole life
growing up I was too scared to get any
other haircut the ski jacket I stole
from my mom
um the glasses were like the glasses I
wear as a kid that made me feel cool the
jinko jeans were like the pants that I
always wanted and the socks and sandals
combo was like the most goony ridiculous
style of Footwear I would wear so it was
pulled together very like you know
authentic to me like I didn't have to
buy the jacket I literally stole it from
my mom's closet and I have pictures of
my parents wearing that my dad wore it
sometimes skiing and my mom would wear
it so it's like a family Relic at this
point but anyways I pulled all that
together and I show up to the music
video shoot and my friend getter who is
one of the studs he like looks right
through me he didn't even recognize me
and I had gone like spent time he showed
me how to produce a lot of uh my
beginning era was like formative years
he showed me how to produce and I showed
him how to DJ and he became a very
successful DJ so it was crazy we both
showed each other so much but he I'd
known him for like six years spent so
much time in high school with him and he
like looked right to me he didn't even
know it was me and then he was like no
way we gotta go film some Vines it was
like back in the vine era and we filmed
these three Vines and this is after I
had already gone through like failed
record career failed like so much stuff
that I've tried so hard to be a serious
artist and then we feel and no one
listens to my music no one cared and
like then we filmed these Vines and the
first one got posted this one and it got
like maybe one or two million in the
first couple days and then like then he
posted another one and it was us dancing
and that one got a million in the first
day or two and then posted another one
that one got me and I was like what the
hell is going on here I spent my whole
life making art nobody cares and somehow
now I've figured out that this I didn't
even have to try I just show up looking
silly and that's what people want to see
they didn't even care so I was like so
then that just sort of like informed a
new approach to everything that you
tried before and all of a sudden it
started working it was fairly calculated
because I had the strategy I'm gonna go
in this is what I want to wear but that
was also playing a cashier in this video
and like they're like you can't wear the
jacket you can't wear this like it
doesn't fit the story and I was like all
right that's fine but anyways I just saw
I was like that was the original plan
look that I wanted to do and I was like
this really worked too well I was like
how is this way more potent than the art
I've been making so I was like how do I
find a way to use this look and really
like maximize on it to use it as a
vehicle to pull all these people over to
my music and that first I kind of was
like weary I was like I don't really
want to like make it forced promotion of
the songs so I just kind of developed
the Persona and kind of developed trying
to make it so that this character could
kind of live in the internet and not
necessarily make it like this guy's a
musician so people were like no this guy
makes music but it's like no it's the
other way around I always made music no
one just cared about it and no one gave
a so I was like I was able to kind
of like slowly ease in and I have this
idea and I think you've executed this
very well but it's like when you are
um someone who really loves to do
something and you have built an audience
you could shift the audience to
something else like if I wanted to be
the world's greatest Chef I could be
like hey guys I've actually always been
a chef and follow along with me on this
journey and if you make it as authentic
as you can they're there for you
obviously they want to see a certain
thing like they want to see your stunts
but that doesn't mean they don't want to
see you do your comedy specials or the
different things obviously there's a
crossover and you have these Venn
diagrams of different levels of like
okay this audience likes the stunts this
audience likes the comedy this audience
likes and there's like you know maybe 20
of them for someone like you and myself
as well where you have the super fans is
where they all interlap in the center
you know there's like the super fandom
and then there's people across the board
who are all kind of it's not like
they're just gonna like one thing
they'll probably be able to cross into
other ones they might be like Stevo's
comedy is trash I'm not gonna listen to
that but everything else they love or
they're like it's called me so funny I
don't really want to see them naked
though you know what I mean and it's I
experience that all the time with what I
do do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is Stevo's butt wipes for
your butt hole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah I do